i got in trouble for whistling at night
because like it'll call spirits
it was like the most ridiculous folklore
hi i'm rithik i'm reino i'm isabella
pacino i'm salvador
tatiana he's my father i'm ritek's mom
better not be getting any more boys why
would you say boys
plural
because they're all compliments
i'm from sapporo japan i grew up in new
york i was born in the same hospital as
my mom so i lived in india for five
years
before moving here i'm a first
generation american
mexicano i grew up in easterly
mom what was your first kiss like and
who was it with my husband your dad
on the marriage day we were so tired we
were given a room
and i was so i just want to uh
go on the bed but then uh your dad
kissed me for the first time i don't
know why she's so awkward about they've
been married for 25
years i guess we'll have to make this
time count
where was your first kiss my first kiss
was i'm surprised yeah i come to know
yeah she had no idea yeah she's like it
was in a parking lot in
my car after the movies oh my god my mom
is literally just finding out right now
that i've even
kissed someone ever
you kissing your father's ashes have
barely begun to drift out to sea
get on this car bye bye
you said at 16 you guys went to the club
yeah and that is very bad things to do
[Laughter]
my class teacher and his friends
was walking around and catching the
students like me
and they wanted to see my inside of my
past
and there was a cigarette and then
there was a ticket from the club
i was you know suspended i had no idea
let's blow the roof off this mother yeah
but
let's also make sure people pick up
after themselves
it happened like the summer after high
school actually i think it was like with
one of my friends
for our first day actually we went on a
hike when we went to go watch the movies
after
mine was a arranged marriage so
you know we didn't meet before and now
in his generation
i want him to decide on his own maybe
you want to
come over for dinner tomorrow night
dinner
at your house you and me eating together
at the same table boy i wasn't allowed
to date
i was not allowed to date um i'm in a
mexican household i'm not even allowed
to leave the house
until i'm married so no i wasn't allowed
to date
what is a boy doing in your room with
the door closed mom
i'm just tutoring him fine but you can
you can tutor him from further away
right move
it's studying not tango class i have you
know quite a few girlfriends
he was a player no no no big deal so
you're saying i should just have two
boyfriends definitely not
my first breakup i'm still in pain
[Laughter]
i have this girl her name is monica
do you remember her name yes oh and and
i love her
man so i'm sorry you know what
i was at 14. yes
i was super devastated after my first
breakup i was in college when that
breakup sort of happened so my dad was
like he felt bad
he just he was like man i knew i
shouldn't have let you go out with no
boys
i don't know what i was thinking and i
was like it's okay like
this happens first break up was about 21
i moved on to another person that's all
no maybe for him maybe
my mom is a savage dude
[Laughter]
all these years paid off you know she
went to college
that was my goal not to go to the
olympics or
you know to get an education to get
something i never have
was college an option for you dad no no
by 18 you were already trying to cross
to come to the stage i'm already in tj
he was trying to cross
by the time he was supposed to be in
college i go to my dad for a lot of
things
he's very important to me my mom is like
kind of like my role model and always
there to come for me
i think we're still very close i love
her with all my heart